movies about the lives of men and women  in the history books have long been a  staples of storytellers sometimes the  names and deeds of the heroes and those  films are known to all and then there  are those films that shine a spotlight  on those whose names were known to only  a few but whose story deserves to be  told we were honored to be in an  inspiring film about three such women  Dorothy Vaughan Mary Jackson and  Catherine Johnson whose brilliance made  access whose brilliance made our  nation's achievements in space possible  and now please welcome a true NASA an  American hero Catherine Johnson  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  thank thanks very much while hidden  figures  [Applause]